3 pas de lancer de chapeau cette année
aux raisons du protocole sanitaire après
une édition 2010 est annulée en raison
de la crise la cérémonie 2021 s'est bien
tenue et l'encours récompense chaque
année les futurs collégiens
c'était très important est ce qu'en fait
c'est c'est le moment on passe aux
sixième et a grandi je vais rencontrer
beaucoup de personnes je vais apprendre
beaucoup de langues
beaucoup de matière ça sera un souvenir
et oui ce serait très important
j'étais un peu stressé au début mes
affaires et qu'il y avait des copains
donc quand j'ai monté sur scène bernard
rigoler et tout ça dans un émoi et des
près de 400 élèves de cm2 ont été reçus
lors des cinq soirées organisées au
prisme du 14 au 22 juin ils se sont vus
notamment remettre un diplôme et une
calculatrice
c'est important de donner des
renforcements positif aux enfants ils
ont besoin d'être aimés ils ont besoin
d'être reconnus et c'est comme ça que
quand ils se sentent reconnus ils
travaillent plus font plus d'efforts
donc c'est très important ils encourent
tous ces rites autour de l'engagement
scolaire de deux aussi de l'esprit
collectif de toutes les équipes soient
les profs les parents les enfants à tout
le personnel qui vise en quarts aile les
élans courtois seront en cm2 encore
quelques jours les vacances scolaires
d'été débute le 6 juillet prochain au
soir deux mois de repos avant d'entrer
dans le secondaire